[Music]
welcome everyone to another episode of
qb talks my guest today is a well-known
composer at valve who has worked on
franchises such as half-life portal team
fortress and a whole lot more he has a
broad skill set he is a programmer he is
a visual effects artist an animator you
name it he can probably do it mike
moresky how you doing
hey nice to be here yeah yeah thanks for
taking time out of your day to to do
this
um first thing i wanted to ask is when
it comes to composing right because most
composers they usually stay in that
sphere like the audio sphere or the
sound design the engineering but
obviously you have a broad skill set
is have you been able to transfer a lot
of skills from those areas into music
somehow
like from visual effects or even
programming
is there anything you can take from it
that's actually a really interesting
good question because i'm like total
process nut like i'm really interested
in the process of creativity whether it
be something woo-woo like you know i
need to sit in front of the sunset you
know like for an hour before i can you
know come up with whatever or um you
know for that matter recording music is
often almost like acting you know like
you have to really be in the mood to get
to really capture some sorts of feels or
be like a consummate professional and be
able to really understand the fine
nuances of performing something in a in
a particular mood um but when it comes
to like actual the process of creating
things on a
like a production you know kind of like
in the trenches um soldiering basically
for you know getting getting a
production done there is just tons of
sort of cross concepts there in terms of
like prioritizing your time and choosing
which things to um really invest like uh
like creative space in you know if
you're gonna really push the boundaries
in some creative way there's there's
you know ways to sort of
optimize that so that you get the
biggest bang for your buck and
you get the least risk for what you're
doing um and so i think that is probably
the stuff that is the most
this you know most similar across the
different domains and um and then
communication you know that's obviously
a really big one um but composing music
is
really uh
you know
music and audio in general are just such
unique art forms um
um music in particular it's kind of the
most abstract um and famously so right
like you can kind of go yeah that
you know piece of orchestral work sounds
like a you know storm at sea or whatever
but if no one told you in advance
like would you actually go oh yeah that
that was a i just listened to a storm at
sea probably not you know what i mean um
and so because of that abstract nature
of it it's
it's it's
it's hard to talk about with you know uh
civilians right like people who
aren't other composers um or have some
form of of musical education or having
spent you know
everyone listens to music therefore
everyone's kind of an expert at music
except for when you start to talk about
actually creating it and um and
discussing ways to make it function you
know uh more applicably to whatever the
project is does that make sense yeah but
there's like a science to it right like
even if you talk about something like eq
right and frequencies and when you start
doing different layers of different
tracks like there'll be certain
instruments that might clash with the
same instruments in the same frequency
range for example so that's very aware
of stuff like that so
um
some composers they think about that in
in
after they've already started composing
but are you thinking for about that from
the get-go like i cannot use this
instrument because
this might clash with another instrument
that i want to use or do you kind of
figure it out
further along in the pipeline
i think it's probably a bit of both for
sure you know i that
from the very beginning on any project
i'm striving to have a structure that i
can understand and has those elements to
it so that um
i put it it's like a skeleton so that as
you work you're working uh within
constraints that make sense for the
project and have design ideas behind
them like why i'm choosing to use this
instrument over that instrument can be
that i don't want it to clash because i
know i'm going to be using
you know some other instrument that's in
the same range as that one
but usually it's also kind of uh built
around some concept of like oh well but
i'm also using that instrument because
it represents this idea for this
character or this location or this uh
form of game data that i'm trying to
communicate and so it's kind of a it's a
multi-tiered
um
structure that i usually try and come up
with that's serving the function of
guiding my compositions but also
really ideally serving the product as a
whole you know both
aesthetically speaking like as a you
know like a brand right a you know team
fortress it's you know like there's some
obvious things happening there that
support the idea of of team fortress
sort of 1960s
you know mercenary team uh vibe uh but
also at the same time um
you know team fortress isn't a good
example because there's not a lot of
in-game music but you know let's say
left 4 dead or something there's a huge
structure there that really is um
designed to serve the game you know on a
whole bunch of different levels and at
the same time
structured so that
musically speaking it's not clashing um
from an information
information theory standpoint which is
kind of what you're talking about i i i
know i'm kind of talking in circles a
little bit but no i do not know it's
good it's good it's good i do think
there's real similarities like i think
of one of the very first shots i did on
um laura the rings uh we were i was
working in the massive department you
know we were doing these big crowd
simulations you know so you've got let's
say 100 uh orcs or whatever doing some
scene
and um
i
set it up so that you know like with
traditional sort of um
design concepts in mind so that your eye
is guided by this one character runs out
and then there's like a little scene
where that character is and then
everyone else is doing you know there's
i think the goal is to get maybe 300
peop you know characters out there doing
stuff and they're all doing their their
um
their ai based animation and everyone
was just really really impressed with
how well the scene worked because the
first one that had really sold this idea
of a crowd
and really all it was is just
traditional design you know it was like
i was guiding your eyes so that you were
really focused on this action that was
happening that was also ai but you know
then everything else was was noise or
whatever you know kind of crowd crowd
animation and so
it's the exact same kind of thing that
you do with
a lot of composing not not always but
similar things that you you kind of have
to think of um
what what the overall experience is and
how are you fitting into it and you know
with video games i spent a lot a lot of
time thinking about um how is is are you
mentally engaged you know um and
physically too like are you using
controllers or a mouse and keyboard and
so you've got this physical interaction
as well as mental engagement if i'm just
pushing way too much musical information
at the same time you're trying to figure
something out
you know that there's a clash there too
it's not just you know a you know a
trumpet with a you know another
instrument that might clash
it's like if that trumpet's really
active and you're trying to figure
something out
it might you might end up with a player
who's like
you know oh my god make that trumpet
stop because i can't think you know well
wasn't that what you had to
or that that was part of the challenge
in half-life alex you had to pull back a
bit like yeah developers wanted more
silence and parts or
more ambient pieces where the music's
not as much in your face
well it was really interesting that one
at first you know that was probably
three plus year project i was on and at
first you know we're developing the
index alongside of it we had the vive
right um and so
uh
we could
uh you know do tests and stuff um but i
was sort of testing and this is a
problem with a lot of games in general
is if you're i like to be involved
really early on because it gives you
more time to work on stuff and sort of
uh come up with different ideas and
explore explore things um but sometimes
you can be exploring too early and so i
was trying some things that where
i hadn't had a chance to establish that
music was being used like a film and so
there'd suddenly be music and people be
like whoa whoa like you know that's
that's not right like where's the music
coming from you know it's vr or whatever
like um and so
uh so i really did back off for a long
time and i think regrettably to a degree
because i think it it i i didn't have as
much time to do a work on some of the
things i would have liked to but um what
i later figured out is that i was gonna
really need like i was gonna need to use
some music like film you know to kind of
say hey this is a big adventure this is
a epic experience right which is sort of
what film music often does um and so i
had moved into a more ambient space and
there's a lot of stuff in there that is
you know really crosses the line between
diegetic and non-diegetic like the
music's actually literally coming from
some machine or something like that um
but so what i ended up doing is really
early in the film i just went ahead and
just did some music that was um
really very classically cinema sounding
you know so it's like oh right there's a
film score happening right now and what
it did is it kind of
set the stage so then when i did it
later on
um people wouldn't be surprised or feel
weird about it in vr does that make
sense yeah yeah no it does make sense
but from
from a challenging aspect was that like
the hardest soundtrack to work on i mean
i mean it's a massive soundtrack and
because you're incorporating vr
um
you're entering new territory pretty
much
it was it was
you know other than
you know the the normal challenges of
like when i very first started valve
there was you know a lot of challenges
there just because i've never worked at
a game company before um and technically
speaking there was just a lot to be done
but yeah this
alex was by far the most challenging um
for just a lot a ton of different
reasons vr was one
um you know it's half-life so there's
just a ton of pressure um and you know
kelly bailey had done all the music to
previous half-lives that's right
um and so
you know and i like i said i like to
have a structure i like to have sort of
a bible and you know a design bible
before i go into something and so you
know i had to i studied his music just
inside and out and
you know kind of came up with
you know my own
design that
you know because it's also not gordon
it's alex and it's in a time period
that's in between you know uh the you
know half-life one and two and so
um
i sort of you know designed it as if
it were kelly
working in that you know like
2002 or three you know somewhere in
there um
and you know and then i had to kind of
make it my own two to a degree just to
just to get it done you know yeah
so you mentioned that you like like
structure
how did you find it adapting to
valve's philosophy then because it
doesn't have a hierarchical structure
does it
no it doesn't so
was it was it easy to adapt to that sort
of um way of working or did it take you
a while
it definitely took me a while i think it
was probably harder for me than some
people some people really take to it
easily um
i and i it's ironic because i come from
a really um
punk rock background you know really
anti-authoritarian sort of
you know no bosses or whatever um but at
the same time
it took me a while to realize um that
in that space where you know when you
have a boss you have somebody to
complain about or somebody to blame you
know to blame right and when there's
nobody above you it really is a
a different sense you kind of have to
it's a real adjustment because you
really there's no one but you you know
and and eventually you learn it's your
colleagues and the you know it's it's
putting a lot of trust in the people
that are around you
and and realizing more importantly that
they trust you you know or gaining that
trust and so um yeah it's that part was
a big adjustment i just come from
working on giant films
which
are about as hierarchical as it gets you
know um
and uh and also there's uh
there was definitely a lot of learning
around um you know i'm a musician right
and an experimental one you know uh
at that um and so
like i said there's a lot of um
a lot of
my investment as an artist has been in
culturing emotions and really being able
to it's like an acting you know like i
said earlier it's sort of like you know
you really are taking an emotion
amplifying it and overselling it through
your guitar or your piano playing or
whatever it happens to be
and you know i get to valve and
for valve to function the way it does
everyone has to have a certain level of
object objectivity and sort of
you know making good decisions and
making right not not impulse driven you
know yeah i'm pissed off you know like
those are not the kinds of decisions you
want to be making at a place like that
you want to be objectively thinking
things through and and so it did take me
a while to
adjust just even my inner personality to
um to not function more on an impulse
level which is kind of more the art side
of things typically speaking and and
find out finding a way to meld those two
things together
um
and so
i so in that way it's interesting i yeah
i mean you're the way you pose the
question is like the valve doesn't have
structure
um but hierarchical structure but
obviously there's some sort of structure
there otherwise
nothing would come out ever right
and the truth is is there is sort of a
hierarchical structure of sorts it's
just not explicit it's implicit and it's
ever-changing you know what i mean um
every project you work on you kind of
figure out where you sit and who you
trust and and also like who on this
project needs
to be given responsibility or given
power right because
you know it's there's always going to be
somebody who's going to lead or that is
going to manage all the the bug triage
or or whatever and as long as you're
watching and paying attention
um you can grant them that power
over you you know and if other people
see you doing that then
as a group you kind of we all sort of
end up agreeing hey we're going to let
this person you know let is not quite
the right word but we're going to you
know observe their necessity for having
a certain amount of power right
yeah that makes sense
yeah and it's it's i mean it's people
act like it's a really and i know when i
got there i was just like now i remember
having dinner with gabe and going
this is just now come on like
tell me how does this actually work you
know um
but uh but it really does but it's also
you got to learn how to function in that
space and
and
you know realize we're all human and you
know yeah
but like some composers right they find
it difficult if they don't have a
deadline
right so they need to be pushed
sometimes in order to finish something
otherwise
they can get too many ideas and they end
up going all over the place both both um
mentally and musically um so did did you
have that problem or were you able to
just
almost develop tunnel vision and just
focus on the the task at hand regardless
of
if there was some sort of deadline
no one's like creeping over your
shoulder
so to speak no i i i it i think i fall
somewhere sort of
in the middle i i saw your uh
conversation with eric you know um and i
definitely can fall into that role of
i'm going to put it off until
like i have to get it done
but usually if i'm doing that it's
because i don't have a full
understanding of what it is i'm trying
to accomplish
you know i can i can just make music um
but that that's where the structure part
comes in right is that uh
it's sort of i don't i i'm a big
i i'm a big fan of um film theory and
eisenstein theory and films are the
worst the worst case right because
you've got this hour and a half long
story you have to tell and if you're
let's say a director out shooting and
you're just willy-nilly shooting
actors acting this way and that way um
it won't tie together as a whole right
and that's why a lot of films fail um
and eisenstein was the first guy to sort
of identify this idea that you need
an overall principle i mean he is
russian so of course it's you know very
um ideology ideologically based um but
the idea is that you know you have this
overall principle that you're trying to
communicate and therefore every time
you're shooting or you're working on
something you're keeping that in mind
and that's where my structures kind of
come from is just trying to build up so
that when i do work on a piece of music
i know what the goal is for it um and
and therefore i can tell if i'm
succeeding or not because really at the
end of the day like
you know i'm a workaholic i love to work
like that's just i'm not an anti like i
understand problems and crunches and
especially getting old like i have to be
careful for my health but like i love
the work of it right and um and we can
talk about that more if you want but um
but the problem is and so i i'm happy to
work on something forever but if i don't
know what the goal is or what i'm trying
to achieve with it or have some sort of
deeper structure that i'm trying to
satisfy
then it is sort of like you're just
working and like uh you know and which
you know i'm i know i kind of i tend to
talk in circles but um
you know it's it's also why i like to
get in on a project early
but often the project doesn't really
solidify till later too so it's kind of
this mixed bag of you can get in early
and try stuff but it's often later in
the project when the real
um
design of it and requirements and
whatnot become clear
and that's you know that's that's when i
really dig in
um you know i
i've heard other composers talk about
like when they start especially film
because film is a more con usually it's
like a three or four month period right
and well it's it's usually quite intense
for a small block as opposed to games
which is stretched over a longer period
right so yeah yeah exactly and a lot of
them will talk about the same thing
where the first month or whatever
they're just messing around and sleeping
a lot you know um and then and so what
you know in my mind what that is is like
kind of collecting up all the ideas i
like during the early phases i'll you
know i'll sit the piano a ton
and just kind of
mess around but trying to find
sort of again like maybe a musical
structure some themes some you know some
uh harmonic motions that feel like the
right um structure to work from going
forward and i'll kind of collect up a
you know in my mind i'll write them down
and then when the time comes like when
it is like go tiger because like you
said game you know you can be going hard
for a year easily
um um but when that time comes then i'll
have like a collection of ideas and
bigger like
themes
like more like narrative themes or you
know musical themes too but um not just
like you know
the theme for the game i mean like kind
of bigger structures that that you're
you know like oh i i want to you know
like with alex you know at the beginning
the music's fairly
cinema
and standard
and it's the reason is is because over
the course of the the game she like
slowly but surely gets into weirder and
weirder places and more extreme horror
and
and alien um experiences and you know
she's also this young woman who's kind
of been in a
you know admittedly a tough existence
but the way we structured it was like oh
they were you know kind of doing heists
and stuff you know they're fighting in
the resistance you know um but then she
goes off and it's this you know the
whole
story from there is gets darker and
darker and darker and her role in it
gets deeper and deeper and heavier and
heavier and so by the end you know
you're in the vault where all of reality
is upside down you know um and so
you know once i wrap my head around that
and the sorts of things i'm going to do
to facilitate that then then okay i'm
going to work on this music over here i
know it should be fairly standard if
it's in the middle somewhere it should
be kind of halfway between crazy out
here
you know what i mean and
yeah makes sense when you're in
wellington and you're working on lord of
the rings
did you i mean
were you still interested in what the
film score was going to be like like i
mean obviously wellington's very
self-contained right and it's probably a
lot easier to network with different
people so if like when howard shaw would
have been there for a period of time
were you able to meet with us i was i
was not um you know i was
i was
high up enough that like i spent a lot
of time with peter jackson and like i
definitely had access to those people if
i want i wanted and and i like i said i
directed you know all the fellowship
characters so um i would see them and we
would talk and and whatnot but
um i wasn't really it's interesting i
wasn't aware at that time that this is
what i wanted to do oh like okay yeah
truthfully i mean i've played music
since i was you know a young teenager
and very seriously like i studied and
um and have
spent pretty much my whole life up until
sort of the late 90s or mid 90s um
in studios right so i did go visit they
had a production
you know studio there and i went and
visited that so i was checking out their
you know their recording rooms and
mixing consoles and sound designers and
i met those guys um
and so that was interesting but i was um
very
uh
clearly for me in my mind i was
pursuing a different path during that
period
i had a studio at home in breaker bay
you know that i i made lots of i always
am recording music like i have never not
done that um so i made a bunch of tapes
of various things that
you know of varying degrees of
interesting or not interesting um but um
i was
i was not planning on coming back to
music necessarily
um
so how did that how did that happen like
how did you come back to music if if you
weren't even on that path
i mean it's you know it's such a great
story i feel you know it's a funny one i
like i said i always played but uh
during that period i was kind of really
moving away from my you know
experimental noise
background a bit and so i was playing a
lot of
actually that guitar right there is this
teeny mexican nylon string classical
guitar um and so i was playing a lot but
i just nothing was really striking me as
interesting to do and i was really into
the film thing you know i was really
into working on big films and doing
animation and um sort of the impact of
that
and when i moved back to the bay area um
and was working on the matrix films
i
have a friend who um had we had been in
a band together before and was doing he
was a producer like he's a real good
studio engineer um and he had started
doing music
for soundtracks
and had invited me into a studio to play
some guitar
and i played like sitar and guitar for
him um
and just didn't i didn't really think
much about it like it was fun because
you know i love going to the studio but
it wasn't just didn't really i you know
i was working all the time so i wasn't
really thinking about it and then i went
to see
[Music]
some film it might have even no it
wouldn't have been one of the lord of
the rings films but anyway i went to see
some film at the local theater
and um you know the screen went black
and this like guitar just came out so
loud like and i was like god i really
that is so familiar
and then this trailer came up and it was
the film that my friend had worked on
and it was my guitar right and it was
just like
blasting in this theater i mean it was
you know proper size a real theater and
a real trailer and i was just like holy
that's me
like that's me you know and all of a
sudden like all the the you know the the
gears clicked into place i was like oh
wait
like maybe i wanted that's what i should
be doing
um
and then it was kind of a slow process
from there
um into
you know getting back into it because i
you know i had like i said i had spent
10 years not really
focusing on you know all the technology
and
and whatnot that goes into
to producing music yeah of that sort um
and had never really written yeah i'd
done sort of some
half-assed writing for orchestra in the
past but not like i hadn't really sat
down and thought about it and um and
exercised through all the different
things you need to to know to do it um
and uh
and so right and then right around that
same time
my friend bae rate who
designed gollum's face on lord of the
rings had signed on at valve and was
working on the sfm
and we and we go way back like uh we
worked at this animation studio together
in the mid-90s
um which was kind of one of the first
stepping stones to me to going to film
in fact he was the one that brought me
to new zealand he was like ah dude you
gotta come down here this is amazing
like you guys this whole scene is crazy
um but he kind of did the same thing at
valve but he was trying to hire me to do
animation
and and that sort of thing
and i was just like no i'm i'm good here
if i'm going to do animation i kind of
want to stay in film
um but valve was really interesting to
me
for a whole bunch of reasons and i was
like but if you guys you know i'm
thinking about scoring and doing um you
know
it's you know scores for film
i'd be interested in that and so he
talked to kelly and kelly's like now i
you know if if we're gonna hire somebody
i'd rather hire a programmer to take
over my programming chops and and i was
like yeah i don't i don't want to do
that really um and so we kind of
stopped talking about it but i kept
doing some side work for valve that was
animation centric some uh technical
stuff and whatnot um and then kept
scoring for small films and and stuff
like that anyway so long story short you
know nine months later or something
bae and i are talking and i say oh yeah
i'm going to this film that my music is
in and he's like wait you're still doing
that i was like yeah and he said well
you know i think kelly's too busy to
finish this current set of games we have
and so let me check and see and that was
kind of early days you know like
on the orange box and uh
it just so happened that kelly's like
yeah let's bring him up and i went up
and kind of spent two weeks there which
is an unusual usually the process is
you know the interview process is pretty
intensive but this was like two weeks of
me actually just seeing what it was like
for them to see what it was like to have
me there um
and whether it was valuable from a game
development standpoint and film
development still because we were doing
the sfm stuff yeah yeah um
you know and and i think it came back uh
super clear that it was valuable to have
a composer in the room
um and then i then i went through the
the uh gauntlet of a valve interview
um which was what did you say the
gauntlet of valve interviews or like
what do you mean like do you have to
have multiple interviews like five
interviews or is it like really like an
interrogation or what are we talking
about yeah it's it's i mean having i now
that i'm on the other you know i've been
there almost 20 years so
um
i'll try to present it from the the
user's perspective is yeah it's like a
day of interviews um with different
people from different domains right um
who interview you on different
topics or sort of domains that one would
hope that you would be able to
communicate about um and understand
um and so
uh
you know in an ideal situation you're
there for three or four interviews and
then you're just offered a job right
away
you know the standard one is like you're
there all day long it's five interviews
um of of different so topics in
different it's usually two or three
people who are talking to you about
whatever the topic uh that your domain
sort of lends you you know it's it's
it's it's hard like i did one on writing
writing for games for example right
right um and so
you know uh because i'm a composer you
would hope that i could communicate
about writing some story for game
and so we worked through this this
example the test case where i was
writing for this scenario um and it was
interesting because i was writing as if
it were a film right like the story i
came up with was solving all the
problems of the film and at the end you
know the the
it was usually we don't do this but at
the end um the one of the people who was
interviewing me when actually like this
is how i would do it right because
it's actually you know here's how i
would write it because we're trying to
get you to do these you know uh game
mechanics and and work with your way
through it so um it's it's sort of it's
sort of that but yeah so it's exhausting
and it's yeah it sounds like it like how
do you stay alert
for that long if it's like a whole day
of interviews
like you have to stay alert and you
don't want to say something stupid
either right yeah well you know i mean
yeah it's uh like again i don't want to
go into it too much no no but hey it
worked out because obviously you're
there so
you did everything right and you know at
the end of the day too i think uh i
genuinely think having been on the other
side of many many of those interviews
the real goal is to um
just
discern it's it's not it's it's weird i
know this is going to sound almost trite
or something but the goal is to to
not
hire somebody that doesn't
is not going to be happy there and is
you know if you're not going to function
in that environment very well if you're
not going to be able to communicate
about
the things you're working on or maybe
something someone else is working on
right because that's the other thing is
there's no producers or um
people to tell people what to work on so
if you need to recruit you have an idea
let's say for example i'm like oh the
the big energy conveyor to the to the
vault should be multiple strings that
are humming at frequencies that makes
this music right and and i you know i've
been there long enough i'm like oh i'm
gonna go talk to tristan because tristan
you know we've done similar things in
the past and he'll kind of and he was
already designing it anyway and so you
know but he'll say like oh okay well
that's great but here's how i'm doing
the you know i'm animating the textures
you know i'm using i'm animating the uv
coordinates for the textures you know
and and so and the timer i don't know
what the timer is for animating the uv
coordinates and so i'm like
okay i got to figure out what time base
we're working in so that i can sync
the audio up with his anime you know i
mean and so
you know when you're when you're
recruiting people on a direct level like
that you
you don't have to be able to speak their
language but it really helps you know
and so that's a lot of that's a lot of
what what happens
um when
you know when valve is is
interviewing people for jobs not always
every job is different i don't know what
like a
you know an art interview loop looks
like or
you know i've seen you know like
um but
at the end of the day you know i got
through the loop so yeah well yeah
you're in a good space so it's it's good
and then spend a couple years like going
oh what is this place
so what's the dynamic like say
obviously with someone like gabe
as opposed to someone like peter jackson
because obviously you have interactions
with
or head interactions with both of them
mm-hmm because
they seem like completely different
individuals
just yeah from various interviews and
i mean obviously i don't know either one
of them but
um i mean you know
you know peter jackson and the
wachowskis are also really different
people um yeah you know everyone's
different but they're all very powerful
which is um i think is is a notable
thing that it's impossible to ignore
really um but you kind of i don't know i
you know i've also met a lot of really
super famous celebrities
and
it's just easier if you just kind of cut
past it and go to the work you know um
and and then your personalities will
either drive or they won't or whatever
like that's just a human's like that's
just how we are but if we've got the
work in common
then there's sort of an ally ship that
can happen that really helps you cut
through um the the you know the sort of
surface social stuff that can get in the
way um yeah
you know the the wachowskis and peter
jackson are of the film world so there
is a cultural
like
similarity there right um and film is
intrinsically a
uh hierarchical and social beast right
you know you've got actors that you need
to
convince in one way or another to do the
performance that you're hoping for or
even just for them to want to do the job
as well as you want them to do it right
whereas games are a much more isolated
you know it's a lot of a lot of work at
the computer a lot of programmery stuff
so there that the culture of game
studios is going to be
different just by design um and by by
nature i think um then film
um
and you know gabe definitely uh comes
from that world he's a he's a programmer
and a good one
um and
he is uh
i think probably the biggest
overt difference
um that
i would
and you know i mean i don't know what
the wachowskis think about or don't
think about or peter jackson for that
matter but gabe is definitely
thinking big picture like he is he is
the quintessential visionary you know at
valve um not that he's like
turning the wheel and steering the ship
and saying hey everybody let's go
but you know
i remember going to lunch with him
wanting to talk about something fairly
you know specific like i i forget like
we just wanna i
something i needed to do so that's going
to be fairly constrained and like
over the next week
i need to sit down and do this work and
i'm just wondering what you think about
it and all of a sudden we're talking
about using you know uh
financial economic systems to guide the
experience shall game play in a
multiplayer something something you know
it was probably early dota days so it
was probably something along those lines
and you know it was like uh okay like i
like i'm i'm like just keeping up like i
can usually keep up with um what he has
to say
um but at the same time it's like okay
you're like you're looking really you
know
further down the road and and thinking
about some big picture stuff that i like
i still just need to actually execute
this thing this week and you know so um
i really i'm a huge fan though i
uh even after the interview loop and
everything um i was not sure i wanted to
go work at valve to be totally honest um
i wasn't sure i wanted to move um
and uh and i was a brief conversation
with him that i had after the loop
that you know it was still it was much
smaller company back then you know i
know 40 50 people yeah yeah of course
now and so of course you would go sit
with gabe after an interview luke um
and uh
and he said something along the lines of
you know
we just
do the best work we can to
make our customers happy our players he
didn't even call him he would never call
them customers he would say like you
know our users or our players
and and if we do that because i was
probably asking them like how
you know making films here because
that's what we were doing at the time is
sfm work that was sort of the team i was
joining up with initially
um you know and he basically was like
you know the money will work itself out
if we're making people happy
like the money will work itself out and
uh and he's you know what it didn't
sound like a platitude you know um
and then on top of that like he uh
i think he's
probably the single largest advocate and
reason the company has managed to stay
a flat structure all these years and and
successfully so
which is really i think an important
thing to keep in mind because
he's the one ostensibly with the most
power
right yeah in any any other traditional
company he would be right um and so
i just have ultimate respect for that
for sure
i'm hoping there's something you can
maybe nip in the bud here because i
think this is something that kind of got
taken out of context and got blown up on
the internet so obviously during the
pandemic or the height of the pandemic
he was in new zealand stranded in new
zealand well i don't know if you want to
use stranded as the word because it
looked like he was having the time of
his life but
um
he mentioned to the new zealand media
that
they were considering
putting a valve office in new zealand
like maybe setting one up right
and if if uh the trajectory of the
pandemic was that um we were gonna be in
lockdown for like years and years on end
but do you remember internally if that
was actually ever a thing because it
sounds like it was something that was
maybe just
it was something that was just put out
there maybe just to feel it out but
nothing concrete was ever
uh set in stone because
it seems like it blew up on the internet
and became this large thing
um and i was thinking i'm not sure
that's quite what he meant
yeah i um i definitely remember it
because we're all like getting on zoom
and you know hanging out
and having meetings and and a lot of
those meetings were just you know us
bullshitting because you know um it was
the pandemic and we just shipped alex
too so we're kind of in a mellow phase
anyway um
so you know and and often too beca again
without you know a direct clear
hierarchy we often learn about stuff in
the news just like everybody else um
and that we all were like whoa okay um
it wouldn't
all i know is is i wasn't
you know i i wasn't singing in meetings
with the people would who would be
having those conversations i could have
you know again it's valve anybody could
sit in those meetings if they really
wanted to yeah but um i just like often
don't see much value to it for me or
from me either direction
um and particularly in that case you
know um i was you know just
watching netflix like everybody else um
but i i do think that
you know he was probably quite serious i
do recall
you know i went and googled and checked
all the little interviews i could find
on the topic and i do recall him saying
like it like the idea wasn't necessarily
to
move valve to new zealand it was more
like to have a place where
maybe hiring some kiwis could happen you
know i that's what i recall it kind of
being a little
bit more like but i really don't know it
wouldn't be the first time it has the
topic has come up uh in the past not
necessarily new zealand but hawaii has
come up you know somewhere that doesn't
rain nine months nine months out of the
year um
you know so
um
yeah i don't like yeah again i i i'm
sorry i wish i could dispel or no no no
hey i just think it was something that
was blown way out of proportion and i
think people were getting their hopes up
and i was thinking um
i think it's a little too early to and
like look i just know how the internet
works i mean you just said right you
often read stuff in the news and you're
like huh okay
you know someone someone from valve
speaks about something and it blows up
into this big thing and
yeah
people didn't even know about so
yeah i i mean i personally have to be
really careful just because people are
always looking for some little tidbit of
something of course yeah yeah yeah
and can you imagine if you're gabe like
that would be a you know he just really
because he's you know he's
again
one of the smartest people i've ever met
and i've met some really smart people in
my day um
and
but he's also a human
can he has you know moments where he can
say things off the cuff too just like
anybody i don't know i'm not saying
that's what that was but you know if he
does man you know he's going to hear
about it in the news for a while right
yeah particularly in this day and age
with journalism as as soon as a
journalist hears
they'll probably aha i can turn this
into an article or something you know
like a five-second snippet and make you
know this huge page article out of it so
yeah i i can understand how someone can
say something and it can be misconstrued
you know or taken out of context or
blown up into something that it
not necessarily is so
that's that's why i wanted to ask
because i'm like i'm pretty sure that
was not the case but i wasn't i wasn't
you'd know but
yeah i was i was not you know i was not
doing zooms with gabe at the time and
and uh
you know as far as i understand he's
he's back in
at ahq so um yeah he's back in seattle
right yeah yeah yeah yeah though he's
got residency now in new zealand lucky
good for him i know yeah yeah i wish i
wish i had gotten it while i was there
so oh you didn't get it you did you want
to get it or
just yeah i know i i you know we uh we
left we we had planned to stay longer
but uh my wife got pregnant and we
decided to leave instead of stay and get
citizenship for our daughter but that's
you know that's a long story we just
needed we smart i think we smartly
moved to be near family fair enough
yeah that makes sense i mean new
zealand's quite isolated did you manage
to attend the premiere in wellington
yeah yeah yeah i did yeah it was great
yeah that looked like um looked like
total madness like the whole city was
the whole city it turned out
yeah it was great with the big orc or
the the the troll at the front of the
theater and yeah the whole thing was
totally madness it was great and i went
to the wrap party i still have all my
every now and again i go through boxes
and it's like oh it's my invitation to
the wrap party my invitation to the
premiere the
you know
all kinds of fun stuff that came from
that yeah so were you still in
wellington when
um return of the king won like 11 oscars
no i had left we left sort of in during
the production of the second film
oh right okay all right yeah because i
work
because you're listed as working on the
two towers and return of the king but
was it fellowship in the two towers
i well i did pre-production for all
three
like i did all right
pre-production yeah like because that's
the thing is i the whole first
i want to say the whole first year i was
there
all we were doing was pre-production
like um you know because they were out
shooting all three films right and um
and they hadn't started production on or
post-production on the first film yet
and so somewhere about you know
nine ten months in then we finally were
actually making the first film um which
wrapped pretty fast you know
post-production happened
shockingly quick
um and then immediately we were just
working on the second film you know
did you understand the gravity of what
you were working on at the time
um
i you know
no i mean you you could imagine i guess
you know i mean you know if you look at
i mean i was a fan of peter jackson's
work previous to that but it wasn't of
anywhere near the scope that this turned
into
um although we did i i do remember you
know it's just like any project there's
you know that you you talk i'm sorry i'm
gonna cycle back but you know the whole
thing of like uh putting work off until
the last second and whatnot like i
understand that but
what that really comes down to is every
project i don't care what it is at some
point
you have to kind of go oh this is a
huge project
and the fear of failure has to hit like
oh it doesn't have to but it always does
like there's some point where all like
even on alex you know almost 20 years
into working at valve you know suddenly
i'm like oh this is going to be
real big
i really need to do like i need to make
sure i don't fail you know yeah and um
there was a con preview that we put
together um
for the fellowship
and i remember going we did there were
two screenings one day just because
there's the crew was so big that we had
to kind of go in
in two groups
and
we kind of viewed it you know some weeks
before the con preview was gonna happen
um and
man we came out and everyone was just
like total hang dog like
oh no right but then those following two
or three weeks like
no one was sleeping everyone was you
know just um
working their hardest to make sure that
it didn't fail at khan and then it
didn't you know it was it was a huge
splash i think it was maybe a full half
hour or something it was quite a big
preview you know might have been 15
minutes but it was it was long as i
recall
so do you ever have or still have or
ever had but imposter syndrome where
you're like
what am i doing
or has that never happened like you
always like no i can do this i'm up to
this task
i no i always have it like always um
you know i
imposter at this point like
you gotta kind of go okay like you you
know
if you're if you've had certain amount
of successes you have to sort of admit
that the odds are pretty good you're not
gonna fail you know yeah um
or that you're not an imposter but i
mean here's the thing like
every field has a michael jordan right
like i think that all of us have certain
innate abilities like probably our dna
gives us some little advantage like like
my hands aren't very big like um my
piano playing would be so much better if
i had another inch on every finger you
know like seriously like i would be a
much much better guitar player so on and
so forth there's those things but we all
kind of then trade off like the things
we focus on we choose to focus on we
don't focus on you know but usually
you're you're taking from one area to
feed the other right like if you're
really good at one thing you know but
then there's the michael jordan
characters who are like
they jump they run they you know they've
got big hands you know like they they
can do everything
and they kind of set the bar for not
imposter
you know
yeah
and then the rest of us are always kind
of like oh but you know i only do this
part
but you know um
so i you know yeah i do suffer from it i
i suffer more from
um
just
this
like i said this
knowledge that failure is the default
right like that you don't
it's not you can't just like kick back
and it's all gonna succeed and be
amazing right like you gotta work it's a
it's
if you're gonna work at any at level
that's sort of near like lord of the
rings or you know half-life games or
whatever you got to work really hard you
know and and and then there's always
this fear of like oh what if you're
making bad choices and what not but um
but that's where that's where valve's
kind of theory and plan works pretty
well because hopefully
you've learned by working with your
colleagues how to make good the best
choices possible given
you know the
amount of information and the sort of
prioritization that is being made and um
so yeah i definitely suffer from it um
but i also just um
i i definitely use work to not think
about it
yes
dig in and work really hard and and
and then you know sort of go well
you know hopefully i didn't make too
many bad choices
wow i think you've made some pretty good
choices given your career
just saying
thank you yeah i'll be i'm ready with it
i'd be pretty slow with it i wish it did
you know i mean not many people could
say they composed for portal 2 and also
did visual effects on like what's
considered you know possibly the
greatest film trilogy of all time so hey
i'd take it
yeah it's so funny i'd rarely think
about it that way but thank you that
that uh makes me feel like less of an
imposter briefly
okay well if i can tell from anyway i
suppose that's that's good um because
one of the good things um and i'll
probably wrap up here but like you have
been able to create so many different
sound palettes right so or musical
palettes like team fortress 2 the music
sounds very different from the for dead
which sounds very different from portal
2 and even half-life alex
so is it very challenging every time
because you're almost creating a new
musical palette and i suppose the longer
you do it in your career the harder it
gets because you've got
less room to
find a new
sound or you musical sound or of some
sort yeah no that's a that's a actually
a really great observation um
it uh for whatever reason i
decided really early on that like genre
and and like sound palette or however
you want to describe it was part of my
palette you know it's part of my the the
tools that i can use
um and so
it does sort of end up
presenting a challenge in from a design
standpoint but i also really view it
from a design standpoint um
you know i go after these things kind of
going you know what everything from you
know the story of course like the the
big arc of the story like what's the the
cell like what's alex gonna experience
what who is she at the beginning who is
she at the end all that stuff but i'm
also looking at it from a brand
standpoint another valve kind of thing
is that of course i am good friends with
the person who's probably going to at
the end of the day being like oh here's
how we present it to the public here's
the types of ads we're going to do or
not do or how you know what i mean or
you know what the the artwork's gonna
look like and so i'm always thinking
about that stuff too along the way and
so i'm trying to satisfy all of the
above at once
um and
it would be way easier if i were just
like you know i'm just i just use
orchestra and you know i just do
i don't know romantic mid-century
stuff or whatever you know like it would
be way way way way easier on me um
but uh
but you know i i i don't know i think
i definitely have a certain amount of um
like
i don't
i don't want to
miss appropriate a word but like a
certain amount of ocd or a certain
amount of sort of i need to satisfy a
certain number of
check boxes when i'm working on
something
and i think the design side of it is a
huge st will always be a huge one for me
um making sure that i can say this
entire piece
um
of music
for the whole thing matches the product
in a way that is satisfying i
i mean i don't want this is like i can
veer off into a whole other topic but i
have a certain amount of synesthesia
which
is i and i've since since kind of
realizing this um i i now realize there
are other composers who have a this
similar form of synesthesia which is
when i hear music i kind of see in my
mind not like necessarily my eyes this
really difficult to describe um kind of
3d
abstract sculpture
um and it kind of has some color to it
but it has a has like a feeling to it a
very distinct feeling um and
and so
often when i'm composing
uh i will see or work on some visual or
you know play some gameplay and i'll
immediately know
what i need what piece what the music
is for that
but i know it in this
weird
3d thing in my brain that i can't
that i then have to write the music to
satisfy that thing right and it's
it's a really weird thing but i have
heard other um professional composers
talk about that um again it'd probably
be a lot easier on me if i heard music
and saw notes on a staff you know them
um but
i you know because of this thing
um
music will sound wrong to like in
concert with a product or in concert
with game play if it doesn't satisfy
this sort of
um other
representation that i have in my head
that i can then pair with things
differently than just like hearing it i
mean i hear music too and i can play it
back in my head and all that but um
it's a
it's definitely i'm working to satisfy a
bunch of different
avenues and um
and design is is a huge one for me so
yeah
uh
you know hopefully valve has enough
sequels in us that i can just work in
the like the ones i've designed already
yeah well hey um we won't we won't go
into sequels and anything because
that can they can go down the rabbit
hole but um the good thing about music
is there's no template so
if it works for you it works for you
that's all they're right that's right
well honestly i'm almost more afraid of
like doing a team fortress 3 or you know
portal 3 would be fun because i could
explore that that musical space you know
for a long time i don't think i'd have
any issues with just exploring that
again but dean fortress i have really
mined that 60s feeling um quite a bit
the you know the 60s meets uh italian
cinema kind of thing um and so if if
we're to do it i i would definitely have
to spend some time thinking about
what a new team fortress would sound
like you know
hopefully it'd be set in a different era
so then yeah
and you'd have to worry about the
expectations as well to live up to the
hype as well which is that's
yeah yeah
well hey i'll um wrap up there thank you
so much for taking time out of your day
i very much appreciate it
uh pleasure yeah if anyone wants to keep
in contact or up to date with what
you're doing is there any any way they
can follow you on any social media or
anything you know mike moraski at
twitter um is that's i use twitter
almost exclusively to talk about work
and so um you don't have to listen to me
talk about politics or any other um
personal stuff uh for the most part
every now and again i'll blab something
out there but uh that's a good way to
find out anything that's that is
happening publicly speaking um and then
there's the there's the contact
there's a the valve has a website
contact thing and i am and it's enabled
for me so you can contact me directly
through the website
um and then and then eventually you'll
get my email
i i don't have any i don't have any
problem emailing with people um you know
gabe does it if gabe can do it i can you
know
soldier on and yeah i don't know how he
finds the time to do it
but yeah it's it's it's amazing it
speaks to the aura of gabe doesn't it so
yeah it does it's it's impressive for
sure um and i i don't always give back
to everybody i try i really do try to
but um you know occasionally they hit me
and it scrolls off the bottom um but i
try pretty hard
all right well um that is the show
everyone make sure you share like and
subscribe support mike and all his uh
future endeavors and i look forward to
seeing more of your work as well
in the future likewise i enjoy your show
so oh thank you appreciate it
all right everyone take care until next
time stay safe
[Music]
you